[Музика]
привіт, мене звати Наталія супер, і
настав час для нашого уроку англійської мови, тож давайте
поговоримо про здорову їжу, тому що ми
знаємо, що якщо ми будемо їсти здорову їжу,
ми будемо щасливі та здорові, і
попередній урок  ми вже пройшли
через усі види продуктів ми помістили
їх у харчову піраміду
ми зробили це будемо на тарілку і тепер ми знаємо,
що буде, якщо ми не будемо пити вісім
склянок води щодня, а також у вас
було домашнє завдання давайте перевіримо  це, щоб
ваше домашнє завдання було вибрати правильне
слово з трьох варіантів і
запишіть речення, а давайте перевіримо його номер
один я люблю перекусити, повертаючись
додому після школи,
я люблю здорову їжу, як-от сирі овочі
сирі овочі та ряд фруктів означає не
приготовані  ви використовуєте свій мозок, щоб навчатися,
а останнє — це свіжі фрукти та
овочі, у них багато вітамінів,
і, як зазвичай, на початку
ми маємо швидкі тести, у цьому нам потрібно,
вам потрібно заповнити пропуски
дієсловом у перервах, тому  Я даю  вам одну хвилину
або близько того, щоб зробити це, а потім ми перевіримо це
[Музика]
чи готові ви
давайте перевіримо Джеррі виграє гру Єва він набере ще
одне очко це перша
умова, і у нас є майбутнє в основній
частині, а теперішнє просте в  якщо
частина речення номер два наші
бабусі й дідусі будуть задоволені, якщо ми відвідаємо
їх у неділю ммм номер три, якщо
на вихідних буде дуже холодно,
ми не підемо в похід у ліс мм-хм,
а номер чотири, якщо ви зробите шум, ви
виграли  не ловити добре рибу,
тому як ми вже знаємо, що
домашня їжа корисніша за
готову, ми вирішили приготувати
вдома, але перед приготуванням нам потрібно купити
продукти, тож ходімо по магазинах
нам потрібні продукти для охолодження де можна
купіть їх, подивіться на це зображення,
тож де ми можемо купити їжу для приготування м'яса,
наприклад, хліб і фрукти та
овочі, подивіться на поле на цю
картинку і знайдіть ці місця,
наприклад, що ми можемо купити м'ясо в
книжковому магазині ні, ми не можемо  що ми можемо
там купити, ми можемо купити їхні книги  добре, чи можемо ми
купити хліб у віолончелістах ні, ми не можемо, тому ми
також закриваємо магазин, у нас також є
пошта, і подивіться вниз, у нас є
м'ясники, пекарі та зелені, так,
це місця, де ми можемо купити всі
ці продукти, м'ясниці м'ясо на м'ясо  у
пекарях ми можемо купити хліб, а в
бакалійних чи зелених магазинах ми можемо купити
фрукти та овочі, але я думаю,
що найкраще місце, де ми можемо купити їжу
, це ринок чи супермаркет, найбільший
вибір продуктів, які ми тут маємо, тож
давайте туди  але перед тим, як йти в
супермаркет, ми повинні мати список покупок,
подивившись на цей список покупок, і в цьому
випадку нам потрібно знати, скільки або
скільки продуктів харчування ми повинні купити для
цього, для цього ми можемо використовувати ці
поради для вечірок або контейнери, де ми  можна купити
продукти наприклад буханець хліба
буханець хліба cebú hunka liebe буханець
хліба не хліб, тому що хліб
незліченний, але буханець хліба ми
можемо порахувати один два три буханки
пучок бананів saputo пучок бананів
банка  варення ви знаєте JA banca
пляшка води коробка соку
підліток сардин підлітка це як консерва
упаковка макаронів коробка борошна, тому що
борошно незлічене, але коли ми поміщаємо
їх у коробку, ми можемо порахувати коробки та
десяток яєць  дюжина, це також можна підрахувати,
але це дванадцять яєць на один
десяток, запам'ятав це, тому ми маємо список
продуктів, тепер ми можемо, нам потрібно знати, як
туди дістатися, наприклад, уявіть, що ми
тут, у парку біля будинку Девіда,
так що ми втопаємо та  скажіть мені, як ми можемо піти
до супермаркету, тож я дам вам
час подумати та скажу напрямок, щоб
напрямок був таким чином, так, йдіть
прямо на Дейл-лейн, потім поверніть ліворуч на
Barry Drive, пройдіть повз паркувальне
місце так, поверніть ліворуч, поверніть ліворуч  знову
на 5th Street Street, і
супермаркет буде зліва від вас, буде
зліва від вас, тому ми прийшли, зараз ми
в супермаркеті, то що нам потрібно,
коли ми зайдемо в супермаркет, коли ми зайдемо
, ми візьмемо кошик для покупок або
кошик так тоді, якщо ми  потрібна допомога, ми
можемо попросити продавець про
допомогу, наприклад, де я можу знайти
кетчуп, де я можу знайти кетчуп, і
продавець може відповісти, що це на проході
, це коридор у супермаркеті,
тож чи у вас є нежирний сир, ви можете
запитай так, у розділі щоденника
це частина супермаркету з деякими
певними продуктами, наприклад, ми можемо побачити
свіжі продукти, свіжі продукти, це фрукти
та овочі, органічні продукти, заморожені,
його розділ щоденника готового м'яса, пекарні,
і це може бути смертельним гастроном,
це означає, що це означає делікатес, це  дуже особлива
або національна кухня, тож йдіть далі,
відповідь може бути шкода, що зараз у нас немає
кетчупу, це означає, що зараз у них немає
кетчупу, вибачте, що немає в наявності,
немає кетчупу, ви можете побачити такі
знаки, як - 20 % або 20  % це означає,
що цей товар має знижку, він
дешевше, ніж раніше, якщо ви не впевнені,
запитайте у продавця, чи це
продається на розпродажі, чи це на розпродажі мм-хм, коли
ви готові заплатити, перейдіть до  ckout
checkout ви можете побачити, що Каса виконана, а
людина, яка там працює, називається
Кеша, але зараз
у супермаркеті є багато кас, де ви
можете
грати самостійно, але коли ви поговорите з
Кешою, вона може запитати вас, як би ви
хотіли  платіть готівкою ми завжди зводимо це в квадрат
дебетовою карткою, якщо ви оплачуєте карткою, будь ласка,
введіть свій PIN-код, персональний ідентифікаційний
номер, ви вводите свій PIN-код, якщо ви платите
готівкою, і загальна сума становить 70 Greeners,
але ви даєте 100 подарунків,
кечер скаже, що ось ваша
зміна  ваша зміна чи ваша зміна 30
гривень добре,
і, звичайно, Кеша дасть
вам квитанцію, це список усіх
продуктів, які ви купили з цінами,
і, звичайно, вона каже або він каже,
гарного дня, тому ми  у нас були списки
продуктів, магазин англійською, ми купили
все, і тепер ми стоїмо
в черзі, просто подивіться на це ліки, тому я
хочу, щоб ми пограли в невелику гру, тому подивіться на
цих людей, які стоять у Cure, і
всі вони мають деякі продукти, які вони
хочуть  я хотів би купити вони хотіли б купити так
і є їх назви я
опишу вам їхній кошик і ви
вгадаєте хто це добре наприклад він
хоче м'яса диню та огірок
він хоче м'яса  диня та купонна
лавка Кімбер, хто він,
так, це Оллі Оллі, давайте спробуємо більше, вона хотіла б,
щоб вона хотіла макарони, трохи хліба та
лимона, вона б хотіла макарони з хліба та
лимон, хто вона,
так, це Емма, це Емма  і останній
і останній вона хотіла б трохи
огірка цибулі та лимона,
вона хотіла б трохи цибулі огірка і
лимона, хто вона
так, це Стейсі, остання в
Cure, добре, тому для мене я віддаю перевагу покупкам
у  продуктовий магазин поруч із моєю квартирою,
ось подивіться на цей слайд,
це діалог між продавщицей
та жінкою, і я прочитаю для вас цей
діалог, і ваше завдання буде прямо
внизу в списку покупок цієї жінки і
вгадайте, яка вона  буду готувати добре, тому
слухай діалог привіт, я можу тобі допомогти
так, будь ласка, я хочу дюжину яєць  і
молоко впевнена, скільки мого молока ти б
хотів, я б хотів дві коробки молока добре що-
небудь ще так маленький пакетик борошна
і пляшка олії
ось буде це все так це все скільки
це це 23 грими тут  ти є, і
ось твоя,
вона мала б гарного дня, дякую до побачення,
тому я даю вам трохи часу, запишіть
список, список покупок цієї жінки і
вгадайте, що вона збирається охолодити так,
це список покупок дюжина яєць два
картонні коробки  молока маленький мішечок борошна
і пляшка олії що це вона
збирається готувати млинці так млинці хороші
так що наступне завдання вибрати правильний варіант
привіт чи можу я вам допомогти і три
варіанти відповіді так, будь ласка, я хочу
пляшку низького  -жирне молоко да допоможіть мені будь ласка і
так я згоден з вами який буде ваш
варіант да перший так будь ласка я
хочу пляшку нежирного молока номер два
де знайти хліб це в
коридорі це в щоденнику  розділ це
в розділі пекарні, і правильною
відповіддю буде це в th  e
розділ хлібобулочних і наступний скільки
коштує перший це мало це 23 грн
і дуже дякую відповідь
це 23 зелень добре а тепер я хотів
би, щоб ми порівняли ці два продукти
ці два продукти
добре я купувала  це в
супермаркеті, але я хочу, щоб ми читали
етикетки, тепер добре, щоб читати етикетки, щоб
зрозуміти, яка з них корисніша,
яку купити, тому давайте подивимося на цю
жовту упаковку, що ми можемо знайти там, ми
можемо знайти інформацію про харчування, пам'ятайте,
що ця інформація  приблизно 100
грамів продукту, тож у 100 грамах продуктів
продукт ми можемо мати скільки енергії
скільки енергії ви бачите 497 кілокалорій кольорів
так, тоді наступний
жир 23 грами добре,
наступний низький, що ми маємо клітковина 2,6
вуглеводи
гідрати 64  грам і сіль одна точка a
81 грам зверніть увагу
на дату виробництва дата виробництва
це дата, як вона була виготовлена, і коли
краще
раніше, коли краще використовувати
до дати добре, це упаковка nu  mber
one і продукт номер два давайте
подивимося на це ця упаковка червона, у
нас є тут декларація про харчову цінність, вони
називають це як декларація для
100 грамів, так скільки енергії скільки у
нас калорій триста 30
кілокалорій 2,2 грама жиру 57 грам
вуглеводів попереду
20 грам клітковини цукру один грам і
білка десять грам, а також ми маємо
масу нетто вагу нетто це вага
тільки всередині продукту без упаковки добре і,
звичайно, день виробництва цей продукт
найкраще до цієї дати зверніть увагу на
ці речі декларація харчової якості  або
інформація вгору та дата продукту, тож що
ви думаєте, щоб порівняти ці два
продукти, давайте складемо таблицю, це
таблиця, де я помітив всю інформацію,
і ми можемо побачити, скільки у нас енергії,
скільки їжі або жиру вуглеводів клітковини
білок і сіль добре  подумайте трохи і
дайте мені свою думку, як ви думаєте,
що здоровіше, червоний чи жовтий
, добре, тому я думаю, що
червоний крапки здоровіше, ніж у  жовтий, тому що
він містить більше клітковини і менше жиру та
солі, як ви думаєте,
дайте мені свій варіант,
і наприкінці я хотів би показати вам ще
одну річ, наприклад, якщо я не
хочу ходити за покупками, я хочу, щоб хтось
ходив по магазинах  цю структуру, яку я
хотів би показати вам, коли хтось хоче, щоб
хтось щось зробив, давайте
розглянемо приклади, щоб було зрозуміло,
номер один мої друзі хочуть, щоб я приготував
вечерю
номер два вона хоче, щоб ви мили посуд
вона не хоче мити посуд  сама
вона хоче, щоб ти помив посуд добре номер
три він хоче, щоб вона пішла додому вона хоче, щоб
вона пішла додому Віньо в магазин були не
тінь Дом о так, номер чотири mark
хоче, щоб вони грали за межами mark хоче
, щоб вони грали за межами
mark Rocha магазин Boni RAL  у знімальному майданчику
номер п'ять вони хочуть, щоб він наполегливо працював,
вони хочуть, щоб він наполегливо працював, і
останнє вона хоче, щоб ми сказали правду, вона
хоче, щоб ми говорили правду, коли
шоу жахів зустрічається з проблемою cazali, тому давайте
тренувати нашу англійську,  виправ
я хотів, щоб
моя мама зробила трохи локшини не так,
правильний варіант я хотів, щоб моя мама зробила
трохи локшини, прочитати це речення, вона
хотіла, щоб Зак спробував шашлик є
помилка тут, і правильний варіант
буде вона хотіла, щоб Зак спробував його інфінітив
спробувати кебаб добре
моя сестра хоче, щоб ми купили рибу та чіпси,
це
ставка тут, а право буде саме
там, де і буде моя сестра хоче, щоб ми
купили рибу і  чіпси наступний Рік хоче, щоб я
приготував рис і квасолю на вечерю,
тоді як помилки тут помиляються добре
Нік хоче або хотів, щоб я приготував рис і
квасолю на вечерю, і останній, що ми
хотіли, щоб наш борг перед обома тако на обід,
помилка полягає в тому, що ми купили, звичайно  ми
хотіли, щоб наш борг купити тако на обід
добре це все на
сьогодні єдине, що у нас тут є - домашнє
завдання домашнє завдання буде написати
речення з цими словами добре напишіть
речення як приклад я моя мама сьогодні приготувала
пасту на обід  реченням буде:
Я хочу, щоб моя мама сьогодні приготувала макарони на обід,
тому
[Музика]
виконайте решту речень самостійно
, будьте здорові та щасливі, дякую і
до побачення,
[Музика]